what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey I'm Sally Sally LeMond
I know man I go is back with us today
today we have a topper war to your video
requests from patron McHale Linden I've
seen a few of our reactor friends
checking this out so I was like thanks
for setting this over away McHale this
video is from the channel dollar
meanwhile in Russia fail / win
compilation but before we go into this
sponsorship time today's video sponsor
is raid shadow legends I'm sure you guys
have heard of them before raid is one of
the most ambitious and immersive mobile
games out there right now and the best
part it's totally free for iOS and
Android the game takes all your favorite
elements of a classic turn-based RPG and
updates them with killer 3d graphics and
cinematic camera angles as well as
collectable and upgradable characters
massive boss and PvP battles and a rich
storyline to tie it all together
plus a brand new login rewards program
for new players it's one of the most
immersive experiences you'll have in
your smartphone so what are you waiting
for what are you waiting for Sally the
games got something for everybody so hit
up our link in the description box pink
comment and join over 10 million players
today download for free
alright Russia we're coming your way
well that's your that whoa
oh they see got out of that really when
Russia's like all the time
I was he not aware what's going on my
whoa
[Laughter]
[Music]
just like that videos to monetize Wow
somebody knows the situation
[Music]
[Music]
haha very sick - casual conversation
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh No
now who's the criminal in that situation
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Russians you really like to dance
oh my god I gotta hit himself put
somewhere he's gonna hurt watermelon
just area
throw a window kick it through a window
barely see it come on guys come on
Jasha we had a flood how they use the
flit but now it was just how low the car
was sitting with all that wood whoa
[Music]
how wait why are they doing this they
can't
[Music]
[Music]
are there like laws about cars or
anything yeah oh my god that's
terrifying I just saw that on the side
of the horse Parker what the hell that's
actually uh I can't watch that no I'm
not oh my god that's so cool skipping
legs
Godfrey smiling Wow oh my god whoa
walked out of there Wow he was like an
action hero that last one you guys see
that you walked out her like it was
nothing so where's like the footage of
them helping out with Trump getting
elected I know that's a definite win and
failed where's the footage of the men
hitting all the women and having no
consequences all the all the different
like generic henchmen and stuff that
make up Russia according to me more
drunk videos why do I want to give props
because what I've learned from this
video is the people at Russia are
excellent at figuring out what to do
when one of your tires is missing yeah
people in Russia seems to be excellent
at using logs to fix almost anything and
balancing out their vehicles when
they're about to tip over are there any
laws towards the road in Russia this is
a really funny and amusing video made me
want to go to Russia it seems like it's
a lot of fun there people are always
dancing like dangers it seem so
dangerous yeah and the amount of people
who are hanging off the side of vehicles
in this video is absurd there has to be
some kind of law on the road because
that one guy on the hood was being
followed by a police car so there's some
yeah some kind of warning you had to do
it in the hood I think he was trying to
be on the hood to like hide from there
maybe he was the first cop who tried to
catch that car and then they were like
oh we need a car we need an actual
cruiser to chase this guy you fit in
great and Russia's
people always think I'm Russian well you
kind of got that like like mean I don't
want to say [ __ ]
I don't want to say [ __ ] you look
Russian I am not touching this I have
nothing against Russian people or
Sally's I'm just making jokes people I
think you're being sincere I think this
video has flavored your entire view of
the Russian people this and stranger
things season 3 Russia feel about half
of our entertainment having them
depicted is just like evil people
accurate like random evil people I think
they're more depicted I was just like
they don't give a [ __ ] this side of
Russia is what we need to see more in
mainstream media all I ever hear about
is how they're the number-one criminals
on the East Coast in mob movies or for
action heroes to take down the war they
colluded with Trump and I'm like that's
not every Russian person much more
nauseous
Oh Russia it's one of the biggest black
countries in the world but we did beat
them to the moon they opened the door
and then we built a house beyond the
door why are we so competitive boot
Russia I don't understand the feud
I like Russian people I don't understand
why there's such a bond man just
indoctrinated us over time I don't know
the Cold War really left an impression
on us as a people I think I think it's
just politics you know you peel back the
curtain and all the people or just you
know regular old people wanting the
world to be a better place just like
wheat well they might call this
meanwhile Russia fail when to me this
video was a complete wid that I've never
seen anything in my life not even the
pictures of historical architecture that
looks so beautiful in films like Mission
Impossible Ghost Protocol
maybe want to go to Russia more than
this video because I want to meet these
people these people seem like a total
blast Sally when are we going to Russia
before school starts really good school
start okay I just need to get a passport
I need to talk to the judge because I'm
not legally allowed to go to Russia do
you think they have red shadow legends
in Russia I'm very sure that you can
play Russian so if you're a Russian
subscriber to this channel hit that link
we actually do have quite a few Russian
subscribers so all unsubscribe since I
started talking guys you can subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell make sure to download
the rage shadow legends game today sadly
where can people find you follow Sally
on YouTube and Instagram also she runs
around the valley of California so just
keep a lookout
occasionally example stock Sally she
will find to be a compliment this is all
just a humble thing she's doing Oh
don't follow me how do you think we
became friends McHale thanks so much for
requesting this buddy McHale you know I
am constantly making fun of our patrons
for not replying to me in a timely
manner
where it'll be like a week or two and
I'm like I haven't heard back from I
don't know what to say and you know what
popped up in my inbox recently McHale
going hey it's been a while since I
heard from you Greg apparently he sent
me a message three weeks went by and I
didn't say anything back to him was this
intentional yes it's the Russians fault
you Swedish bastards just watching
agents of shield in fact and they shot
some of the episode in Sweden and McHale
chimed in that's right McHale said he's
happier watching ages the show because
he's a big fan of the show that's right
love you buddy
see you guys